first game today we can see if it works properly with a slightly
different setting of the screen
opponent is camp in the master 3000 but
doesn't have 3000 but since 2 430 at least took such a
closed variant atalan ischinger
c4 that's usually quite a
comfortable variant for white
it has stop here  good advantage and
switzerland not so easy and problem-
free to free the position here
yes c5 doesn't work now because the rook
on which the line stands and black
really has to
come to 25 at some point because otherwise the b7 bishop would
become a problem in case of a problem
would now with it  c7 maybe
still expect so that you can play eight with seven
I play bishop 4
so now you have to see what you can do
very often against 25 night on the other hand it is
good if you can play the five which
works tactically and more often
one possibility would also be to simply
knight your 5 in the  position to then
play the five
I could also play c5 quite mechanically
prevent with c4 c5 that's the
simplest solution always looks a
bit obligatory when you have the
field you have
actually almost never really a problem so you
should take and take c5
that should probably
pull the bishop
if you don't quite  sure that the best
field we are standing calmly has the
two prepared also the one here is planning to
cover the pawn
again which certainly needs a support here again
so would be ideal for knowing now how to
get something like b43
gutzweiler area two go
I ask  I just think whether
jumper is more direct every five years jumper per
50 depends then he
probably has to make jumper the five
and then I could play with four
whereby jumper the 5 also simply
hitting b 6 comes into consideration 26
depends after
all well what  on the other hand, I don't see it at the
moment
as taking springer
e
find out
for yourself here so that you only have a seven
and therefore check, so I
definitely don't want a move like that for the
king  7
so
I would like to take here with the
rook I could take
more material right here I don't think you
can win the question is whether you want to
take that two runners are good of course he
has a pretty good
blockade and the five but run in again
6 comes then
maybe I'm starving here I'd rather be gone so
now I want to swap the question and I do
n't really like making the
body c4 I wasn't counting on
it pulls he could then
play seven at the
finish ok well that wasn't exactly intended ok
right away  maybe we do
n't take it that great,
so he has the idea that runner e2 could
now play it live, then I'll keep
the b  externally but you get the eternal
jumper on the 5 actually not
so pleasant however if I
do that I don't know if I can really
take here so it really looks
like a stupid self-
pretense maybe it's ok but
if I'm still here like this I can  the
three are playing
the tempi i'll take with me now here
now one has to be done here
or something like that actually the crooked position is
now set to white then as a good
control has
so i've tried to
simplify a bit it also needs a little
bit of time of course  catching up here
playing clothes pleasantly fast
the production is now relatively
easy however I have nothing left
on the
clock actually a total one-way street
game but currently the disadvantage has taken its
revenge he actually
just didn't put it at all then put it
in six way and then make
it white  simple farmers more good for almost
nothing problem w  ar that was the
short time here I always had 20
seconds less the problem is
that I didn’t
catch up with you either unfortunately because he himself is very
fast
it’s not really easy to get
ahead due to the blockade here on the 5th